many of us want to start our own
businesses public space is filled with
reports of new ventures but the
reporting on entrepreneurship is heavily
skewed in one particular direction
towards people who've started new kinds
of businesses pioneers who've pushed the
boundaries of Commerce by creating a
wholly new offering usually through the
help of some form of innovative piece of
technology the new entrepreneurs might
for example have invented an app for
measuring and controlling the humidity
of clothes closets or they might have
come up with a tiny sensor that can
detect hunger in domestic animals or
they've built a social platform to
connect people planning a trip to Italy
this emphasis on novelty can leave us
feeling that the chief and correct way
to become an entrepreneur is invariably
going to be through radical
technologically based innovation we may
therefore as we contemplate an
entrepreneurial future ask ourselves
with increasing panic what entirely
unthought-of idea we might ourselves
come up with to propel us forwards in a
frenzy the answers we arrive at may
start to lean towards the implausible
the trite or the naive but there is
another path most of the economy is made
up of businesses doing stuff that people
have always been doing or have been
doing for a very long time making daily
bread or shirts or trousers teaching
languages or giving travelers a bed for
the night raising animals or fixing
teeth in other words most businesses
operate in areas that economists call
mature sectors where it's rather hard to
come in and make a surprising fortune
but that doesn't mean these sectors
should be ignored far from it there are
a plethora of hugely meaningful
possibilities hiding for us in plain
sight on account of one perhaps
surprising fact about the economy a
majority of businesses don't love what
they do we might make a basic
distinction between two kinds of
businesses pragmatic businesses and
businesses of love
pragmatic businesses are everywhere they
almost define for us what we think
business is in its essence they know how
to make their product or service with a
sound degree of competence but there is
a practical idealistic edge to the way
they go about things
there isn't anything very powerful
drawing them to their particular
offering they might easily have been
doing something else they don't care
about the long term the business is only
a vehicle for an underlying financial
purpose one eye is always focused on how
to sell up if the owners didn't have to
work they will most certainly wouldn't
such pragmatic businesses may do fine or
even very well for a long time but the
motivations are easy enough to spot a
discerning I can tell something crucial
within minutes of walking through the
door this is not being done with or for
love pragmatic businesses dominate the
economy one might say that over 85% of
businesses fall into this category but
there are parts of the economy and they
are heavily in the minority where things
are being done rather differently
businesses of love produce many very
things but there are some underlying
principles holding them together here
love means a total commitment to
excellence of a given product or service
a desire to reinvest almost all profit
into guaranteeing is excellence a focus
on the long term because the business is
for its owners the meaning of life there
is no interest in selling the firm right
now or perhaps ever the dearest wish
might be to give it to someone you love
like your child love means you almost do
it for free and don't only because you
need to live you need to pay your
employees and you want the business to
be able to last into the long term the
product or service is what you love and
you love it inordinately businesses of
love of a sort where the owner has
scoured the world for the best kind of
flower and wakes up excitedly at dawn to
check on the progress of each of the
loaves or the aircraft factory where the
workers think of every plane they're
building almost like a relative they
will always care for or the stationery
shop where notebooks and paper are
viewed as objects of beauty
rather than utility or the travel agency
that won't rest until it knows its
clients have enjoyed their trips rather
than just paid for them or the sandwich
store that views a fine avocados and
chicken roll as one of the authentic
joys in a tricky life businesses run for
love are not always successful in the
standard financial sense of the term
some might just be returning a little
over 3% a year but for these enterprises
money is only ever a means to a greater
more purposeful end there are huge
opportunities to hand for any would-be
entrepreneurs because most of the
economy is in the hands of people who
don't love what they're doing most law
firms dentists offices hotels and
bakeries aren't in it for love they may
be efficient and canny but they are
ultimately just waiting to sell up we
don't need to be very original to
succeed we don't need to have invented
anything very new we just need to make
sense of our lives and make an honest
living along the way to offer the world
something we love a little more
intensely than most people do thank you
for commenting liking and subscribing
our book a job to love is a practical
guide to finding fulfilling work to find
out more follow the link on your screen
now
you